[Musique]
yyuu le monde sait squeeze et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une
nouvelle jamais deux sans trois comme on
dit et vidéo sur s&p 0 96 b mais
attention cette fois c'est une version
créée par l'asie donc pour ma team pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas encore le
non-match m.sellal asie dont kim ont
créé cette petite version d'essai paix
pour fêter mes cent mille abonnés donc
ils m'ont fait ce petit cadeau ainsi
qu'une autre petite vidéo vraiment ils
sont ils sont adorables
encore merci à vous les gars donc
écouter ils m'ont ils ont rien voulu me
dire si c'était fun paf une horreur j'ai
pas lancer le jeu pour pas mais ce pôle
est donc on peut durant ladite image
d'un squeeze crédit quand eris en cas de
ma bannière c'est parti ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas trop je l'aï
long mais l'image s'cusez 115 [ __ ] on
l'espère belles images
je suis sûr que c'est google avait
accordé deux secondes juste inventé
au nom ils sont trop cons ils ont eu des
messages
alors attendez c'est bon j'ai mis sur un
bloc c'est parti ou là
non il ya des visages un peu plus
bombardements une musique un peu à la
halle à exorciste et des fois demandé à
lasi qui sortent un petit message parce
qu il se passe quoi est-ce parce que toi
à à plus tard les gens mais du coup je
ne saurais pas quoi y aura un bon s'il
aura pas de bruit du monstre oh là là
ils sont complètement fêlé aa
on attend les goûts l'équipe 1
j'ai pas mourir maintenant j'espère que
je le verrai le mensonge et la tête de
mons gbc impulsion puisqu'après je
m'emporte cela paraît assez stressant oh
c'est bon c'est par là j'écris qui avait
pas d'issue voilà en tout cas en
attendant moi je propose qu'on porte une
petite chanson 3,4 il est dans la grotte
le monde toi de s&p ils sont
complètement fous avec sa pelle
qu'aujourd'hui il n'est pas vraiment là
le mois suivant l'entente on va arrêter
de chanter déduction de gamme très mal
barré chaud sinon je voulais battre au
témoin ils font peur [ __ ] j'ai juste
envie dans l'humour petit alors on prend
des cours encore quelque chose
d'incroyable qui m'est arrivé j'ai
croisé deux personnes qui m'ont connu
alors on a parlé pendant cinq minutes
vraiment encore une fois je vous dis
merci à tous et à tout parce que si j'en
suis là c'est grâce à vous quand même le
fait d'avoir cent dix mille abonnés
s'est fait remettre conséquent est
énormissime
et encore une fois je tiens vraiment
marcher parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de fou sinon je tenais vraiment à
savoir si la série max payne 3 vous
plaisez le goût de ce trou donc sur un
épisode chaque vendredi et jeudi au
mercredi on va voir donc n'hésitez pas à
laisser dans les commentaires vos avis
[Musique]
assez énorme puissance y faire leur
idylle catégorie a mais non mais les
gens j'essaie d'acheter sont super forts
pour vous puissiez entendre ils sont
complètement fêlé szélesi je vous
promets voilà j'ai bien former une team
des gens les plus bêtes de youtube je
pense oh [ __ ] les mecs quoi vous êtes
sérieux
[ __ ] mais après sur ce cas monsieur je
vous jure je vous crier dessus
non mais sérieusement je sais pas qui
c'est qu'a fait chris ivery blessés méga
horrible [ __ ] mais sérieusement mais
c'est ignoble et en plus vous avez fait
un truc affreux la croix là vous mettez
des trucs flippant parts pouvez vous
crée des trucs pourris il ya un espèce
de dedans mais l'article accapare eu la
cape epic franchement peur ce jeune
homme c'est incroyable oh non mais non
mais non mais si c'était moi je sais que
c'est un atout tant les menesson en
boucle on a fallu que savary pucerons
mais bon après malheureusement ça ça
dépend pas d'eux j'espère juste que
y'aura pas l'aura pas le monstre
élastique qui va apparaître souvent vers
un nouveau monstre le monstre élastique
c'est d'amasser vous avez pas vu le
respect de petites silhouettes tout tout
élasticité est élastique et c'est fou
mais en tout cas sachez que n'importe
quelle version dcp fait peur que ce soit
bon nom sauf la version pro phone la
gérer une version troll est peut-être
sur la vidéo sur un de ces jours ci
jamais jamais trois sans quatre
ou pas bon bref mais là en tout cas
j'avoue que je me fais un peu caca
dessus
ils sont
mais [ __ ] mais c'est la chanson qui te
manque bouffe ça sent le monde a pu
tantôt a déjà créé dans le micro ça fait
péter un câble j'ai l'impression que je
sortais savait qu il parle à mon dieu ça
fait des dégâts
oui bon fiche
[ __ ] bordel le les gars je vous jure
messieurs dames on va aller jusqu'au
bout de leur jeu de merde
les gars je vous emmerde mêlée si je
vous emmerde non sans déconner c'est pas
drôle du tout je vais chercher le jeune
braqueur il est dans le coeur avec sa
thèse comme on dit il nous fait tous les
faits alors comment voilà invite sa
cachette c'est l'homme coton tige
il n'est pas très bien faut condamner
aux tiges bordel quoi je regarde
derrière moi alors tu aura jamais rien à
quoi que les six étaient lents les
pervers mais [ __ ] les mecs mais vous
êtes sérieux en plus voilà je fais demi
tour accueille entre les âges y compris
qu'un vague rose il est donc pour en
faire vous pouvez le faire vous même des
versions de s&p il suffit de modifier
les fichiers sont dans le dossier du jeu
c'est pour ça que c'est comme ça que les
ont fait ça ils ont signifié les
textures en tout cas sachez que ça fait
plutôt le bon si frayeur je dois bien
l'avouer ils ont mis des hommes et ces
offres
oh là là ça sent bon
seulement ça n'avancera pas loin
arriva arrivait vous avez quoi les gens
prochaine fois car monstre lui fonce
dessus en plein pays blais buzz je
n'écris c'est que si tu es tu toi
coûtait pas dollars voilà deux buts
voilà te pique mon micro devant
peut-être deux buts non ça va aller bon
bref l'homme qui bouge ton écran en
plein là m super non franchement c'est
pas sur un an mais les gars vous n'êtes
pas cool je m'attendais à un truc
médiaphones bon antoine a beau dire
qu'il a un gros souci
gilles est l'enfoiré de l'asie qui a
fait ce cri strident qui vient de me
péter les oreilles bordel à mes oreilles
[ __ ] c'est green nakisa à mes oreilles
nouveaux records on est on est à
l'étagement dans les jambes
[ __ ] on y presse ça se pose et
d'attentes matinée mieux malarone canton
tige est ce que tu es là moi je
t'attends on est dans la cave s'est
répétée des mineurs ou peaches et six
boeufs on y est on y est on y est on y
est on est on y est ah non mais les gens
se retrouvent à arriver au flore 40
la prochaine fois les gens on va le
battre on se jette sur lui pour lui
faire un truc à la rambo alors on
continue on
vas-y jetons
alors
à toowoomba et bientôt digues et bien
fait
[Musique]
m